das ist das ist jetzt gerade nicht
wirklich dabei rausgekommen
hallo mein name ist lukan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video erst mal sorry falls ich total
verkehrsstaus sehe ich bin einfach
hässlich also da kann man eigentlich
jetzt auch nicht viel machen näher es
ist gerade 12.30 und ich bin einfach
seit 6 uhr 30 wach weil wir eine uni
präsentation hat nur blablabla gibt auch
keinen von euch eigentlich ich habe auf
jeden fall die tage in video von bibi
gesehen in denen sie geschaut hat ob sie
dazu bereit wäre ein kind zu bekommen
und hat das ganze halt mit einem echten
baby gemacht und gar kein held an dieser
stelle das video war echt nice und recht
unterhaltsam und ich fand es echt cool
und ich habe mir dann halt gedacht ich
hab kein baby hier am start mit dem ich
das machen kann aber es gibt ja die
website texte die ich und habe ich
dieses test gefunden wäre ich eine gute
mutter vater und das wollte ich jetzt
einfach mal eben machen das test um zu
schauen ob ich ein guter vater wäre
irgendwann stellt sich jeder die frage
wo will ich in fünf jahren stehen was
will ich vom leben und lässt dieses
leben platz für ein kind finde es heraus
ob du eine gute mutter beziehungsweise
ein guter vater wärs los geht das ganze
hier ist übrigens ein job also dass es
kein ernst zu nehmender test ich krieg
jetzt den fragen gestellt danach kriege
ich entweder ja du bist geeignet oder
nein also erwartet hier nichts bilden
des falls ihr wirklich gerade angehende
mutter oder ein angehender vater seit
bei mir
mein videos könnt ihr nichts mitnehmen
also erstmal kommen wir gleich zur
ersten frage was in deinem besten
eigenschaften erstens flexibel meistens
gut drauf für vieles offen zweitens
organisatorisch ordentlich gerecht
drittens kreativ liebevoll einfühlsam wo
ist die option dass man pizza mag ich
würde sagen 1 flexibel meistens gut
drauf wie vieles offen
das heißt wir klicke einfach mal auf die
nächste frage wo es ist alles so ein
bisschen verzerrt wo wohnst du
[Musik]
was hat das damit zu tun ob ich ein
guter vater wäre wo ich wohne in einem
mittelgroßen dorf in einer größeren
stadt oder in einer großstadt also ich
weiß nicht ich komme halt gebürtig aus
bielefeld und wohne jetzt gerade in köln
und bielefeld hat 400.000 oder 300.000
einwohner und köln so um die eine
million ich würde sagen in einer
großstadt das ist jetzt natürlich nichts
ultra riesiges aber es ist auf jeden
fall schon eine große stadt also nächste
frage dritte frage bist du in festen
händen ja und wir sind sehr glücklich
nein und ich bin eigentlich auch nicht
aufsuchen
erstens ja aber erst seit kurzem oder
zweitens nein aber ich bin stets auch
suche was ist denn das hier finde ich
würd mal sagen nein und ich bin
eigentlich nicht auf suche also nächste
frage was hältst du von künstlicher
befruchtung ich würde es eher nicht
machen da ich jetzt nicht in ordnung
finde und dem kind zu verheimlichen wer
der vater ist warum nicht ich meine wenn
man einen kinderwunsch hat aber einfach
nicht den richtigen partner findet warum
nicht überhaupt nichts um ein kind
großzuziehen sollte man einen
liebevollen partner haben also ich will
mich jetzt überhaupt nicht negativ
gegenüber künstlicher befruchtung hat
eine ahnung was äußern aber mir ist es
eigentlich komplett egal also jedem das
seine ehrlich gesagt also warum nicht
ich meine wenn man einen kinderwunsch
hat blablabla nächste frage in deinem
freundeskreis bekommt eine deiner
freundin ein kind und sie quatscht
einfach nur noch über kinderplanung was
tust du
[Musik]
ok es klingelt hammer aktion kommen
einfach so studienkollegen rom okay
leute ich bin macht die aufnahme um 18
uhr weiter das heißt das video kommt
relativ spät für euch keinen unterschied
für mich ein bisschen stress bis gleich
ich bin back in meiner wohnung
es ist dunkel draußen ich war die ganze
in der uni pizza pizza pc in deinem
freundeskreis bekommt eine deiner
freundin ein kind und sie quatschen
einfach nur noch über kinderplanung was
tust du erst das interessiert mich
eigentlich nicht ich gehe nach hause
oder treffe mich mit jemand anderem mich
interessiert dass man nicht sonderlich
aber ich bleibe trotzdem dabei das ist
auch toll mit ein paar mädels über
kinder planungen kann sein dass sich das
küstendorf mädels bezieht in der tat ich
würde mal sagen mich interessiert das
war nicht sonderlich aber ich bleibe
trotzdem mit dabei weil es ist schön so
glaube ich wäre mir eine freude erzählt
ich bekommen obwohl eigentlich ist es
doch recht interessant das ist doch toll
mit ein paar mädels über kinder plane
unterhalten
nein du und dein freund habt nicht auf
was für mich und mein freund ich dachte
das ist auch ein vater will wie du okay
du und dein freund hat nicht aufgepasst
du bist schwanger was tut ihr wir freuen
uns total wir wollten sowieso bald damit
anfangen was als wenn man ungeplant und
dann freuen
wir haben einen riesigen schock aber
freuen und später darüber ich habe
keinen freund wie oft noch ich habe halt
wirklich kein freund
wenn schon hätte ich eine freundin dass
die hätte wenigstens überschreiben
können wir werden deinen partner und du
und dann irgendwie aber das bezieht sich
gerade wirklich nur auf frauen also ich
würde auf keinen fall nehmen wir freuen
uns total wir wollten sowieso bald damit
anfangen
eigentlich wenn man doch ein kind machen
will dann macht man auch ein kind wenn
man kein kind machen will dann ist es
auch nicht so schwer dass nicht
hinzukriegen beziehungsweise
hinzukriegen
also wenn man wirklich kein kind machen
will dann kriegt man zu kennen
wirst du etwas meinung ich würde sagen
wir haben einen riesigen schock aber
freuen und später darüber also ich
glaube wenn ich jetzt wirklich sein fell
haben würde dass ich irgendwie beim sex
und dann ich keine ahnung was ich
überhaupt gerade mache spulen wir mal
ein bisschen vor ein kind ist 13 alles
klar wir spielen 13 jahre vor
ok nina heißt die tante lina ja sie
heißt nina dass christus von nina nina
vorspulen ein bisschen 13 jahre dein
kind es 13 und über merkst dass seine
jacke öfters nach rauch stinkt mit 13
hammer erziehung ist der sache nach und
bemerkst dass es heimlich raucht eine
reaktion erwarte auf jeden fall ein
ernstes gespräch und eine straße ich
kann meine kinder nicht mit 13 schon zum
kettenraucher werden lassen ich rede es
war darauf an aber es wird schon sehen
was davon hat gott alter welches
elternteil sagten so war es auf jeden
fall gibt es ein erstes gespräch und in
zukunft werde ich das wohl besser nach
kontrollieren also ich bin auf jeden
fall für 1 mit der strafe ich weiß das
klingt streng und jeder darf eigentlich
machen was er will aber erst mit 18
nicht mit 13 du darfst man also wenden
wenn mein kind mit 13 jahren mit einer
verrauchten jacken nach hause kommt
das ist dass das wäre definitiv nicht
cool ich weiß halt nicht wie ihr die
fragen beantwortet hätte also das könnt
ihr mir mal gerne in die kommentare
schreiben
bei welchen fragen ihr euch denkt luca
halt einfach dein maul du hast überhaupt
keine ahnung das hätte ich komplett
anders beantwortet wer mega interessant
mal zu sehen aber bei der frage wer da
einfach sagt ich rede ist darauf an aber
es wird schon sehen was davon hat er
doch kein herz also das ist doch da der
den den gibt's doch gar nicht was die
kinder machen oder wer würde in deiner
familie die oberhand übernehmen ehrlich
gesagt das weiß ich nicht genau ich
meine das ist doch so weit weg da mache
ich mir dann erst gedanken wenn ich
schwanger sein sollte ich bin immer noch
ein mann
ich kann nicht schwanger sein nina
auf jeden fall die eltern das kind
sollte wissen wer hier der boss ist mal
die oberhand was heißt die oberhand wenn
ich eine familie habe dann dürfen alle
mitbestimmen aber bei wichtigen
entscheidungen natürlich doch die eltern
ich denke jeder ist für diese option mit
wie vielen leuten warst du schon
zusammen vier fünf sechs sieben acht
oder neun das ist das ist ja eine super
spannend 4 5 6 7 8 9 schreibt doch
gleich 1 2367 1929 einsatzdienst 130
anders sein auf einer feder von achim
das anders wie alle seine drei tagen
wird man das sehen wir dann widmen luca
ihr schwarz vor augen ein paar sekunden
später also ich war bisher in
beziehungen mit mädchen glaube ich in
fünf aber das sind nicht alles so
richtige beziehungen gewesen wo man sagt
dass beziehungen sind sondern ein oder
zwei davon zu dem kindergarten gewesen
deswegen sage ich einfach mal 123
was ist das für ein geschrei und zum
schluss was wünscht du dir für die
zukunft endlich meine große liebe finden
und noch einige dinge erledigen aber ich
hätte später schon gerne eine eigene
familie eine große familie und dass alle
gesund und fröhlich bleiben oder ich
habe absolut keine ahnung ich glaube ich
wünsche mir einfach dass alles so bleibt
wie es ist
ich wünsche pizza ja was wünsche ich mir
für die zukunft das ist jetzt natürlich
wieder der krasse frage also immer wenn
ich erhalte mal irgendwie beete oder ja
ich bete manchmal also ich glaube das
ist nichts wofür man sich schämen muss
oder so aber so in der familie so ein
paar gesundheit sachen gibts bei mir
halt derzeit und das gibt es ja glaub
ich in jeder familie das heißt ich
wünsche mir nur gesundheit für alle
menschen die mir nahestehen und für
meine familie aber das bezieht sich auf
dem vaterschaft beziehungsweise
mutterschaft selbst das heißt ich glaube
eine große familie dass alle gesund und
fröhlich bleiben
das kreuz sich einfach mal an
das ist nicht wahr
das ist das ist jetzt gerade nicht
wirklich dabei rausgekommen auswertung
des quizzes wäre ich eine gute mutter
beziehungsweise ein guter vater zu 40
sind wie du wirst die perfekte mutter
hammer
hamma resultat du siehst dich in fünf
jahren ganz klar mit deinem mann und
seiner familie plant schon ein bisschen
und dann disziplin die man zur
kindererziehung braucht fehlt es ihr
offenbar auch nicht das einzige worauf
du achten solltest ist dass du nicht zu
strengen des herzlichen glückwunsch die
goldmedaille das beste ergebnis dieses
tests verdienst dieses profil hat ein 56
prozent der teilnehmer
ich habe noch ein profil ihr ergebnis
waren nicht eindeutig sie hätten noch
das folgende werden können so 40 sind
sie du bist hier ganz und gar nicht
sicher was du eigentlich willst das
solltest du dir auf jeden fall klar sein
was da habe ich sogar nur die
bronzemedaille verdient
das war wieder hammer meine damen und
herren wir haben den heutigen video
einen test gemacht ob ich eine
eigentlich mehr ob ich meine mutter wäre
weil irgendwer sich das test nur frauen
bezogen letztendlich kam zwei
auswaschungen raus und zwar auf der
einen seite eine goldmedaille bekommen
weil ich die perfekte mutter wer auf der
anderen seite bin ich mir überhaupt
nicht sicher was ich haben will dass nur
die bronzemedaille also ich bin alles
scheiße als elternteil und auch gut
irgendwie wenn euch das video hier
gefallen dann würde ich mich riesig über
den daumen hoch freuen schreibt mir mal
in die kommentare wie ihr auf die ganzen
sachen geantwortet hätte ich verlinke
euch hier einen smiley wenn ihr darauf
könnte meinen kanal abonnieren und hier
findet ihr ein video eingeblendet da
könnt ihr eine nintendo 3ds elga will
3ds xl gewinn wenn ihm ein kanal
abonniert und einem kommentar schreibt
derzeit famila view of pizza